welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki just solved one of the
mcu's biggest mysteries since avengers
in-game
the question of where and when exactly
old steve rogers came from and if the
reason we haven't seen him since
is that the tba pruned them in the
middle of being
there quacked in america did he live his
second life in the background of the mcu
we've been watching as the endgame
screenwriters claim
or did going back to 1949 with peggy
carter create a branch
timeline as the end game directors sake
who's really running this cinematic
universe the nerds with the whiteboards
or the broken bros and ball caps
turns out it's whoever makes the next
thing to which kevin feige says sure
that works
loki director kate herron just provided
the clearest explanation yet of cap's
actual fate and current status in the
mcu
at least according to the tva timeline
logic of loki which marvel studios seems
to be holding sacred and before i begin
this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
kate herron said in an interview that
either way steve and peggy were living
in a branch timeline
no debate there but really the question
is whether or not that branch timeline
was
pruned she said optimistic fans could
argue that stephen peggy's branch wasn't
so severe
and maybe it didn't need to be pruned
but she went on to say that in her mind
and according to the logic of the tva
steve
and peggy probably were pruned yikes
scratched that it's been a long long
time
record and crank up the emoji in heap
[Music]
thankfully we can finally dispel with
that weird interpretation that old cap
could have been hiding in the background
of the infinity saga letting every
historical tragedy
happen including his best friend being
tortured for decades by hydra no
steve did create a new branch history
from 1949 onward in which he could have
saved bucky and alter the timeline
however he wanted but now according to
heron that
also would make steve a variant targeted
for pruning and we did speculate on this
earlier in the season like in episode 1
in the background of the tva
a hunter escorts a variant who looks a
lot like peggy carter interestingly when
she was asked about this
directly kate herron refused to debunk
it and deliberately left the door open
for more conversation about possible
prune variant peggy but wait variant
steve couldn't have been pruned right
because he showed up as an old man to
hand off that shield to sam wilson his
survival means the tva must not have
caught him
and in his wedding ring means he must
have had at least some time with peggy
carter at least for the two of them to
rush to a pawn shop in a wedding chapel
before the tva dragged her away
screaming
oh steven i do
i mean i could definitely see that as a
reason old steve didn't want to go into
it you want to tell me about her
no no i don't think i would
[Music]
this is where things get more confusing
because according to he who remains the
tva was created to prune only the branch
timelines that would lead to the rise of
a rival kang
that would help explain why there are so
many alternate loki's who lived varying
lengths of lives before random mistakes
got them pruned now if that throws you
i'll refer you back to my bundle of
strands interpretation of the sacred
timeline that it's not
one timeline it's really coil of
alternate strands
looped back upon themselves endlessly
and they don't interfere with each other
with every universal cycle ending with a
big crunch
and then resetting with a big bang like
bang now we're on a silvia loop bang now
we're on a gator loop etc now heron
complicates it by saying steve and peggy
should have been pruned for
merely existing together unless the
implication is that
every unplanned branch from the curated
timeline would inevitably lead to a kang
it's also possible that steven peggy's
union was the nexus event that led to
the rise of the kang in that timeline
similar to how loki and sylvie's union
was their next event you could even
extrapolate that variance sharing
knowledge
would lead to futures where nathaniel
richards would be more likely to unlock
the secrets of time and transdimensional
travel
but i like to simplify it as kang hates
love look i love crafting these theories
about where the mcu might be heading
maybe you love carving rocket raccoons
out of ice and you need a website to
share your work with the world well
squarespace is an all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
let the world see your frozen trash
pandas
squarespace lets you present members
only gated content connect your social
media accounts
present video content and all the other
cool features to give you a
super effective super functional website
for your hobby or your business
you can collect the emails of fellow ice
guardians of the galaxy enthusiasts
and send custom newsletters squarespace
will even sell you a url
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch
go to squarespace.com new rockstars to
save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain that's squarespace.com
newrockstars for 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain so
again let's ask if old steve rogers was
a variant targeted for pruning by the
tva how did he get away from them and
age into an old man by the end of end
game there are three possibilities at
least first theory
as herons suggested in our interview the
optimist's view that maybe steve and
peggy's branch timeline was just
harmless enough for the tva to leave
them alone
nah i don't think so this organization
is a bunch of dirt bags if they can
prune little
kids newlyweds are not off limits and i
think heron's response to that variant
peggy carter question
suggests the tva did not actually leave
them alone so on to our second theory
steve and peggy found a legal loophole
now it's possible they were
arrested but somewhere in their legal
proceedings they managed to appeal to a
higher authority that ruled that steve
represented a crucial anomaly that
earned him a special immunity from the
tva
we know from the void that the living
tribunal exists in the mcu
now i know it looks like its head has
been severed here so how much authority
could it really have over the tba but
actually i'm pretty sure this is a
statue
of the living tribunal so really what
might have gotten pruned here was a
timeline where the tribunal's rule was
just more public and domineering because
why else does one have a statue of
oneself and he
remains needs the living tribunal to
exercise more judicial restraint
either way steve could argue that him
going that extra mile to patch the
sacred timeline with each of the
infinity stones really earned him a get
out of jail free card ultimately i do
think it makes a lot of sense for steve
to have had some correspondence with the
tva because a time door is just the
cleanest explanation for how he could
show up
by the lake and end game from another
timeline but if all of this is going
down in our head cannons i want to live
in a multiverse recap based off against
the tva so
theory 3 steve and peggy were tva
fugitives
who built their own tva this explanation
would initially mirror loki and silvi's
journey in loki season one like two
variants who slipped in and out of tva
custody
but managed to get enough alone time by
fighting their way out and hiding near
apocalyptic events
but in steve rogers case instead of
letting those apocalyptic events happen
don't you think he and peggy would try
to intervene to save lives perhaps these
two spent their alternate history
fighting to save as many people as
possible from each of those apocalypses
and by doing so
becoming a whole different kind of
frustration for the tva
for thwarting what was dictated in their
script so imagine this history where
steve and peggy strive to write as many
historical wrongs as they could not only
freeing bucky but also freeing isaiah
bradley the widows of the red room
helping the victims of sokovia
the victims of thanos what we're talking
about is really the origins of the
captain britain corps a heroic
multiversal organization
that would be untouchable by the tva but
one that refuses
to let history always end in death and
despair what do you think variant old
steve did in his alternate life and
where is he now
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you